how's it going everybody it's warm
welcome back to my channel to cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and today we have some venom to
news some great news and unfortunately
some bad news as well as venom has
officially been pushed back as no longer
going to be hitting theaters on October
2nd of 2020 but is now going to be
hitting theaters on June 25th of 2021
now sadly this was pretty much expected
to happen as most studios have pushed
the release dates back for most of their
films coming up to next year but as I
mentioned we do have some good news
because the official title for venom 2
has been revealed
today's report comes from variety.com
and they're the ones who broke the
report about venom being pushed back to
next year and their article starts off
by saying Sony's venom sequel officially
titled venom
let there be carnage has delayed its
big-screen debut so the official title
for venom 2 is venom
let there be carnage and honestly it's a
very awesome title it's not maximum
carnage but they've already titled a
comic run that the movie is going to be
a different take on carnage so it would
make sense that the title is different
as well but now everybody's main
question is when is the trailer going to
get here well sadly this definitely
pushes the trailer release date back a
bit sadly at least a couple of months at
the very least because June of 2021 is
over a year away so as far as a teaser
trailer for venom let there be carnage
is concerned we probably won't see any
until at least we're within a year of
the movie coming out and this is why
Sony did not release the trailer before
they were unsure of whether or not they
were going to have to postpone then I
let there be carnage to a later date
which they officially have so very sad
news but also awesome news that we
finally know the official title for
venom 2 venom let there be carnage what
do you think about this title let me
know what you think in the comments down
below leave a like for the new title and
subscribe notifications turned on to
stay up to date on all things relating
to venom 2 and of course Marvel you can
follow me on Twitter for live updates
and as always thank you so much for
watching
woof woof